it's been a while since I talked about
books so I thought I would do a video
this is not a book club because Dan
still has to finish reading the
prehistory of time but that is
definitely coming I thought I'd talk
about what I've been reading recently
these three books I'm going to recommend
two of these and this video is just
going to be me talking about books and
saying what kind of person might enjoy
them starting with one of my favorite
reads of the past couple of years
actually prisoner geography the starting
with prisoners of geography like Tim
Marshall well my favorite read to the
past couple of years this is actually
present at my friend's wedding because I
was an usher which was a really touching
present actually because they're clearly
very well this was a really interesting
book how to describe this the book is
about the field of geopolitics so it's
relating how relations between different
countries are affected by the lay of the
land and by particular geographic
features and it split into ten chapters
on so I'm focusing on a different thing
in each chapter so the first chapter is
about Russia and the whole thing about
Russia is securing its western border
and the other thing is it starts to
graphic chapter that is a map that's the
one for Russia its map of Russia and
focusing in that chapter on the European
Plain and basically maintaining security
of Russia and sort of focusing on you
know how vast the border that is and
also a lot of other courses I'm talking
mostly about NATO and about why Russia
would for example prefer a destabilized
NATO because it means that they can
expand their border further west and
guarantee security because it sort of
cuts off the entry points to the sent
that european plane other chapters focus
on why the USA became such a superpower
by nature of its geography in the
mississippi in particular looking at the
history of western europe looking at the
future of geopolitics in the Arctic by
the fact that you know resources going
to be creasing exploited and then more
contentious places like India and
Pakistan career the Middle East you know
obviously you could write huge textbooks
about each of these issues so the
chapters are quite short introductions
so to be honest if you are a little bit
clueless about world relations like on a
really big scale
not nitty gritty kind of like daily
politics but the big how the nation's
feel about each other kind of thing very
very good read Tim Marshall writes very
well it clearly knows what he's talking
about for experience and relate to
personal experiences talking to
government officials and being on the
ground in these places and just
generally very very clearly written very
interesting subject matter I'd recommend
this to pretty much anybody here as an
interest in either geography or politics
which should be everybody incidentally
if you want a slightly more in-depth
reviews of these I have a Goodreads
which I'll put a couple on screen well
that was a waste of one of those and
they've been linked down there to my
Goodreads there is actually the Simon
ops fizz Book Club where we are all
reading a book together at the moment
that's meant to be a brief history of
time that's one of the people is taking
a while and it's a place for discussion
for people who like books and like my
channel so if you're interested in that
check that out down there and yeah my
particular account has also reviews all
these books
next up the book I've had on my shelf
for a while and I've been told by
basically everybody to read the physics
be impossible by Misha ikkaku this is a
kind of modern classic I guess in
relating science fiction to physics and
I was really hesitant to read it because
I think it's on these books that people
in sixth form read to put on the
university applications basically
comment if that's you by the way I'm
really curious to see how many people
that applies to because it's saying you
know this is an error in physics applies
to a problem like for example
teleportation because that's the way the
book is broken down but in two levels of
impossibility through classes of
impossibility meaning either it's
technically possible like we could do it
now if we really tried things that are
going to possible a few thousand years
in the future because of energy
constraints and some things that are
just outright impossible interestingly
only two things fall into that category
and that's precognition and perpetual
motion machines but other things like
telepathy starships
faster-than-light travel invisibility
they all fall in one of the other two
categories and I kind of wanted to
dislike this book because I felt like
it's a very pulpy way of approaching
this stuff not least because I just make
a few rice
in American because you're the American
and I feel like it's a little bit
hyperbole it's just a little bit I can't
quite put my finger on it but there's
there's something about that is the
style of prose that I just don't
particularly like but it warned me over
by the end of the book not least because
they were bits that even I and I've read
a lot of these books before even I
didn't make connections between
trafficking example some of the stuff to
do with robots and artificial
intelligence was new to me but yeah this
book surprised me actually which it
shouldn't done because like I say it's
kind of a modern classic um so if you
haven't read this already and you're
thinking applying for physical
university or a science definitely check
this one out it is worth reading it's
actually the chapters are such a length
but it's kind of good to read bomb for
bed you know there's nothing there's
nothing too heavy mystery I'm saying
that as the guy trying to do a PhD I
don't think it's too heavy
but I think this would be fine for GCSE
and by a little people then lastly we
come to the book that I wish I could
recommend by can't ie
right I left a long review of this one
on my Goodreads my basic problem with
this is yes I learned a fair bit and
it's subject matter is very interesting
as Stephen Fry is very funny but the way
in which this book is written is
absolutely exhausting to read because he
just changes every like that's a typical
page and if you how are we going to make
that out but like every paragraph or two
it just like goes off on one and it
changes and tries to be funny in a way
that I didn't find funny personally and
whenever I've given it to people to sort
of read quickly they're saying oh wow
yeah I'm getting tired already
I couldn't manage much much longer even
reading through it's making me
frustrated I think there are going to be
better histories of this basically if
you are a massive fan of Stephen Fry
you'll probably like this but oh yeah I
haven't even said what it is here's what
it says in the 10 it's an incomplete
history of classical music from
basically where music began the first
evidence of music and instruments to the
invention of notes and bars and sort of
all the conventions and western music
because I think is only about western
music and it has huge holes it doesn't
really talk about religious music
it gives completely short shrift to
everything in the 20th century basically
it's like he gave up after vogner
because he bloody loves magna doesn't
read it does talk about film music but
in a in a like the book just cut ends in
it's like The Fault in Our Stars and
that like an under it was the book
within the fault in our stars I've put
that was good because I can't remember
and it almost like it ends in the middle
of a sentence like it just goes oh this
is something interesting and now we're
done like doesn't develop it at the end
it builds up quite well I think the
brach periods fine classical periods
fine and then yeah just it goes off the
rails I was I was frustrated by this
more than anything else so sadly not one
I can wholeheartedly recommend to anyone
other than the most die-hard Stephen Fry
fan unincluded links by the way to all
the books I talked about and the Amazon
pages down there in the description and
if you'd like to get in yourself though
where possible do try and support your
local bookshop because they have a bit
more character than just a you know
multinational corporations so that's
what I've been reading recently I've now
moved on to two books and all taneous
leaked how to watch a movie and 15
million degrees this one is a very
theoretical discussion about what it is
to watch a movie and like the experience
of viewing so far a little bit away not
quite short I think about this yet and
this one I've only read the prologue
like the introduction and it seems
interesting so far I mean the Sun is a
really interesting subject so high hopes
for this one and then on the horizon I
have a whole bunch of other books never
that the difference was recommended to
me by sanjeev from Lucchese next up and
this was actually peaceful by advanture
I got from thank you which is a channel
I have talked and talked about on this
channel before I think make great videos
and they sent me about to say thank you
for a shout out so that's what I've
bought with that guys I got sent gastro
physics by L cat penguin and I'm really
excited to read this one actually I'm
kind of saving this one up for when I
really need a good book because from
what I've heard about it it's going to
be great I just impulsively also bought
a history of the world and twelve Maps
because I really like maps and the
history in there and it's amazing
although I look inside this and very
very dense so I may have made a slight
mistake with this one but I'm looking
for supplying through that one and then
lastly possibly the most gorgeous cover
of the book I've ever seen in my life
I basically bought it almost entirely
because of the cover and a little bit of
preparation for crash course Christ bit
because there is a section in of ice but
the water book by Alec jar looking for -
this one again it's probably going to be
kind of similar to physically impossible
in terms of sort of scope and audience
so not expecting groundbreaking stuff if
nothing else that's just gorgeous to
have on a shelf so that's it those are
all the books in my life at the moment
apart from a brief history of time which
is over there off camera and we're down
to left it after having read it we are
going to do a full book club episode
about that is coming just give us a bit
more time if you're reading anything
particularly interesting at the moment
do let me know down there I'm always on
the lookout for recommendations although
you've seen I've got quite the pilot of
readers of this I'll put a link up here
to a playlist of all the book videos
that I've done I do want to do more of
these in the future it's just a bit busy
recently
and if you're new to the channel and you
were looking for something to read and
came across me first of all hello I'll
put a button down there that you can use
to subscribe as well link to all the
books and the Goodreads down there in
the description and do comment with what
you'd recommend
I read next